we accidentally put an influencer in
jail and today I want to tell you the
story of how it happened
24 hours ago I listened on a call as the
popular Instagram influencer Jay mazzini
pled guilty to many of the crimes I
accused him of two years ago and finally
today I can say it's no longer alleged
he said he did it and now he faces
serious prison time for his scams now
not only that he also has to pay
millions of dollars in Damages and this
is such an incredible win for this
channel for what this channel represents
fighting for victims holding scammers
accountable that I just kind of wanted
to take a second to celebrate it because
now if you're an influencer in the past
you were able to just say oh I've got
featured on coffeezilla nothing's gonna
happen
but now you have to wonder you have to
wonder what am I going to be doing in
two years what are my plans
because look probably nothing's going to
happen to you but there's that one
percent chance now
that maybe something will uh and that's
the point now we get to strike fear in
the hearts of these scammers influencers
are going to be launching new nfts
wondering
is coffee still coming for me
and the answer to that question is yes
of course I am now I do want to
obviously say I think this goes without
saying but I'll say it anyways um I
cannot take credit for all of this or
even most of this without your support
none of this would have been possible
without the victims who came forward on
this channel none of this would have
been possible and without law
enforcement who put in two years of like
actual legal work to make this happen
none of this would have been possible so
I'm not trying to say I cuffed the guy
or say anything like that but this
channel played a small role in bringing
this guy to Justice and I am incredibly
proud of that because as I said in the
title this was absolutely not the plan
total accident uh you guys know I mean I
run a YouTube channel most of the time
we cover scammers nothing happens it's a
meme on this channel like hey we covered
this guy we have hard evidence that he
scammed people and nothing happens so I
fully expect it when I covered James
that it would be more of the same he'd
get away with it uh but that didn't
happen because I I think I can talk
about this the way all this unfolded was
so bizarre because one day my wife gets
a call and she's like hello and they're
like hi can we speak to me coffee Zilla
um and we're with so and so some
three-letter government organization and
my wife literally hung up on them she
she thought it was a scam you know I
guess I've taught her well she's like no
shot you would have had his real number
and uh she comes to my office she's like
hey there's this new scam going around
these guys are pretending to be like you
know this real government organization
and they say they wanted to talk to you
whatever obvious scam and I'm looking at
her I'm like is it though like let's
um he was very it's very real so I call
it like so I come back
that's what I'm saying this very much
almost never happened I mean this could
have very much accidental so I call him
back and I'm like uh sorry about that
and so then I talked to them for a bit
and a month later you know I'm watching
this guy plead guilty to a lot of the
very things that uh we accused him of
sorry I saw him get charged two years
later we see him plead guilty to the
stuff we accuse him of and um yeah he
admitted to wire fraud wire fraud
conspiracy and money laundering which I
think the as I said the recommended
sentence is eight to ten years which is
just insane and I think just sets such a
good precedence for people who think
they can scam online and get away with
it they think that just because you're
an influencer the rules don't apply to
you and clearly that's not true so yeah
I just wanted to tell this story I don't
think I've ever shared that part of it
before uh because you know things were
still getting worked out and um
you know it's just it's just wild that a
little Channel like this could have done
much of anything or made a difference
and and yeah I'm really proud of you
guys I'm proud of what we did and I just
wanted to kind of celebrate it's a it's
a really big deal I'm proud of it and uh
thank you guys for sharing this journey
with me if you haven't seen it it's wild
it's been a wild ride
thanks a lot I'll see ya